foreign
to be able to tell you a couple of
stories that I hope you might enjoy uh
the first one is about the town where I
come from uh it's called hotel but uh in
South Wales uh it's sort of I guess
famous for a couple of things it's got a
steel works so sort of mainly
working-class Town built up around the
steel Works big Council estate to house
the workers there that my grandparents
grew up on uh and that my parents grew
up on as well
um and uh it's also I suppose known for
weirdly actors
um and uh I said that this story was
going to be about the town it's actually
about a couple of people who come from
the town
so this first story was told to me it's
from the horse's mouth
so one of the uh legendary uh sons of
potalbot is of course the great actor
Richard Burton
and The Story Goes that uh the Richard
Burton at the height of his Fame uh came
back to patalbert and was staying at his
uh Elder sister's house who
actually raised him uh in Patel and they
were there in Sissy's house in patelbert
and there was a knock on the door and
since he went to open the door and it
was a young young lad and uh and he said
this young lad said um
is Richard burden there and uh that's
just he was like
but she come there's a vladia to see him
so Richard Burton comes down and this
young man standing there looking at him
it's the Great Richard Burton and uh
says he says this this young lad wants
an autograph and Burton said uh do you
speak Welsh
[Music]
and uh says this this lad he's the
son of uh the the beakers on the corner
it's down down from where the region
Cinema is and Burton said to this little
that uh I used to work at the uh Co-op
just up the road from the cinema I was
hopeless
and this little lad couldn't believe it
he got his autograph and this little ad
grew up into a man who told me that Not
only was this an extraordinary moment
for him because it was Richard Burton
who was doing
on the biggest stage what he hoped that
he would do when he grew up but also
because this little lad felt like he was
a bit he was always told that he was a
bit stupid a bit top as we'd say in
Wales and Richard Burton the Great
Richard Burton saying that he he was
always a bit hopeless as well gave him
such hope
now that little ad I grew up to be
Anthony Hopkins
and Anthony Hopkins told me that story
and I me myself growing up in Port
Albert it was knowing out there and
being Richard Burton and out there now
was Anthony Hopkins two people who came
from the same town as me who sounded
like me a bit uh looked a bit like me
and but we're out there if it was
possible for them
then maybe it would be possible for me
now that
is an incredibly important thing
to see your background your experience
your history represented out there in
the world having a voice speaking on a
platform doing the things that perhaps
you hope that you would be able to do if
you can't see yourself out there or
anyone who looks like you or sounds like
you
it's very hard to imagine that you'll be
able to do that as well and that's one
part
of what was incredibly important I've
realized over the years of what was
incredibly important about me being able
to have the life and the opportunities
in the career
that I've had
but it's only one part
I've realized more and more as time has
gone on
how much I owe
everything all the opportunities I've
had to other people and the work of
other people
I come from an incredibly supportive
family
my all my family were into performing in
some way amateur performing in some way
so I knew from a very early age that it
was something that you could do and that
uh and that you've got sort of Brown new
points for
um so that was important and as time
went on my family were always there to
take me to school rehearsals in the
evening use theater whatever it might be
they come and see me in any performance
I was doing and that
meant a lot it's it's meant a lot more
to me as time has gone on because of
course I took everything for granted
didn't I at the time
um but uh but having that supportive
family was incredibly important
and coming from a community
a a working-class community like for
Talbot steel town it's not somewhere
that you would expect to be that
supportive of people going into the
Ponce art you know
um but Richard Burton had done it
Anthony Hopkins had done it and there
was a there was a kind of nobility to it
there was certainly a respectability to
it and a respect for what they had done
and so that made a big difference
but in some ways I think the most
important part was that I was able to do
performances in School drama in school
and then I auditioned for a youth
theater local Youth Theater it's the
County Youth Theater and again at the
time I took it all for granted but now I
look back and I can see that there was
an incredibly
um
powerful youth Arts infrastructure that
had grown up in the area not by chance
it hadn't happened randomly it was
because one man a man called Godfrey
Evans who was the uh was a teacher at
the at the comprehensive school on the
sandfields estate that was the estate
that housed the steel workers families
he had created an incredibly kind of
progressive liberal uh theater program
in that comprehensive school and
eventually that spread to the entire
County and he became the chief advisor
of County
of drama and dance in the county and
created the youth theater that I was a
product of that Russell T Davis was a
product of many many people they used
dance company the Catherine Zeta Jones
was a product of the the orchestra the
The Brass Band it was an incredible
diverse array of of Arts all funded
through the education system and I was
absolutely a product of that
and I
joined the youth theater and at a
certain point everyone in IU theater
just auditioned for drama schools got in
went off to drama schools in London
went into the profession I never
questioned it I didn't think
that was strange or odd your name it was
just like that's what happened and so
that's what I did and I got a grant to
be able to go to Radha in London and
came to Radha and then uh and then left
radar went straight into the West End
doing a play with Vanessa raygrave never
looked back
as time has gone on
I've seen that pathway let's call it
um disappear
so I know that
if I was around now starting off that
pathway wouldn't be there
and I had tremendous advantages I
realized now
with the family community all kinds of
things
and it does make me worry that not only
has my pathway disappeared
my school
um stopped doing drama school closed
down eventually the youth theater lost
its funding grants weren't available
anymore for people to go to drama school
[Music]
um so I've seen my footsteps kind of
disappear and I think and if someone
like myself with all the advantages I
had wouldn't be able to do it what about
the kids who out there who don't have
those advantages who don't have maybe a
family who can take them to abuse
theater rehearsals or you know whatever
it might be don't have a school to
pushed them don't have that kind of
infrastructure there to to create that
pathway for them what happens to them
and then that leads to a bigger question
I suppose of if if young people
coming from certain kinds of working
class backgrounds
aren't able to come through into the
Arts I mean I was an actor but it could
be any anything within the Arts or
creative Industries
um or journalism writing
the conversation that we have
as a as a country as a as a nation as a
community
what is that conversation like if we're
only hearing from the people who are
able to afford to get through to the
point where they get to speak get to
have a voice
it makes that conversation incredibly
one-sided
um I mean there are figures that you
know I can quote you that I'll just keep
to a few but uh the office of national
statistics uh reported a few years back
that
uh of all writers in Britain uh
came from the most privileged social
starting points compared to 10 coming
from working class backgrounds
uh the Sutton trust report in 2019 said
that of newspaper columnists so these
are the people who are really got a big
part to play in in setting what our
national conversation is our newspaper
columnist across the political Spectrum
44 of those newspaper columnists come
from Independent Schools whereas only
seven percent of the population
generally go to Independent Schools so
there's a massive over-representation
there
um and of those newspaper columnists 33
one in three uh are part of that
Independent School Oxbridge pathway
pipeline
and those are the people who are you
know the enormous part to play in
setting what our conversation is you
know who gets to speak who gets to tell
their story and how does it get told
and if that pathway
is there for people coming through
Independent Schools and through Oxbridge
and that's not just into acting or
writing that's across you know the top
jobs across our whole nation
where are those other Pathways for
people who are not coming from those
sorts of backgrounds
it's so important that we start early to
create those Pathways in some ways I
feel like it's too late by the time
you're 1819 out in the world what how do
you get people young people young kids
to feel like there's something out there
for them that they see themselves
represented and know that it's possible
as as Anthony Hopkins did with Richard
Burton as I did with them
and how how do you then create the
pathway from that moment
and let's say that that moment happens
where you see the possibility for you
doing something
where's that yellow brick road that goes
from there all the way to actually
getting into the industry that you want
to be in if that pathway doesn't exist
because it certainly exists for some
people it doesn't exist for you because
of some accident of birth and geography
what happens then there will always be
individuals
who are able to break through in some
way or get support and and become the
exception to the rule but how do we
change
structurally our system so it's not just
about individuals breaking through that
everyone gets the same opportunity
so I found myself sitting at my kitchen
table during the first lockdown talking
to Professor Katie Shaw about a project
that she had been involved with that I
was incredibly inspired by The Common
People project
I suddenly had a grandiose vision of
supporting people coming from working
class backgrounds and underrepresented
backgrounds
in storytelling
and we started to hammer out an idea for
a project that could go out into
communities and towns and look for those
people we started to think about a
project where people were given the
opportunity asked to to get involved
um and that were then supported through
it and were would get mentors
so people who've already
made a mark in the industry and the
areas that they wanted to helping them
support them advising them giving them a
bit of confidence and then to create a
platform for what came out of it to be
shared nationally and to try and
influence industry and whether it's
Publishers or you know broadcasters or
whoever it might be to open their doors
and first of all to acknowledge the
difficulties and the obstacles and then
encourage people to come in to to to to
to renew us
to hear voices that we've not heard from
historically
um and to hear of those experiences and
those stories told by themselves
rather than having their story told at
them or to them that people are able to
actually tell their own stories and we
believed that that would be an
incredibly powerful thing not only for
the individuals involved but for all of
us and so a writing chance was born
through that conversation really we have
11 people eventually who got through to
be that our first cohort who would go
through the the program and get
mentoring and get the financial support
and everything else and I remember
reading Stephen tuffins piece that he
submitted
um which was about uh
caring for his mother in her final days
and
I remember thinking not only is this one
of the most moving things I've read in
this
in these submissions this is one of the
most moving things I'd ever read it was
an extraordinary
searing incredibly Raw
beautiful piece of writing
and in that moment I knew
that this was going to exceed all
expectations
and it did
the 11 writers that we finally
worked with for the last year
reading what they've done has been
absolutely revelatory
whether it's reading about the
experience of marginalized bodies by
grace quantock
lifting the veil on uh what it is like
to live with a disability and how people
relate to that
it's an extraordinary everything she's
written has been extraordinary
Stevens piece which about
caring for his his mother
in our final days I as I as I will never
forget that piece it will stay with me
for the rest of my life
um
there's David Clancy hairdresser in
ulverston talking about how he turned
being having jobs thrown at him for
being gay when he was younger being
kicked out of his own house by his
parents
um
for being gay and then having to move
back into the house with his mum or
choosing to move back into the house
with his mother and father as uh as the
pandemic struck in order to look after
them that experience
um whether it's mayor Jordan
coming to write her novel about the
goddess of the river seven
um these are incredible pieces of
writing from and with voices and
experiences that I just never heard
before
absolutely revelatory to me to see their
writing on a magazine on a national
newspaper being performed live on stage
being broadcast on on BBC's hands in the
podcast this is extraordinary stuff my I
remember mayor Jordan telling me that
when the idea of being a writer on her
estate she said there were no writers on
ice skate to say to someone that you
wanted to be a writer was like saying
you wanted to be an astronaut it was
amazing to be able to go up to to Mayor
after the uh after the live performance
that we did in Cardiff and to say to us
all how does it feel to be an astronaut
[Music]